pilot season mm yes and know what I mean
what's going on towards the end while
trying to salt three ship yeah but you
didn't go out at all or not it got there
wasn't a lot of good roles for this type
and why a lot of stuff was offered this
year they were celeb two people with a
lot of credits Wow
so that's how they're doing it now a lot
of the new kids were like we were going
crazy like going out like for everything
last year this year was like not really
and if you weren't you it was all the
Indian people there were a lot of Indian
pilots oh really it was like the hottest
Asians are in our Indians Wow
three like Indian pilots yeah there's
three Indian pilots yeah that's cool you
didn't go out a lot
no but after more probably guessed our
auditions after that yeah hot season I
really have been thinking about you and
I really really seriously need you to
make it here yes he's carving his own
path though because he's writing his own
yeah yeah I just really need you to step
it up a bit okay okay thank you so much
what else is going on with you I don't
ever talk to you you know when you come
into my house riot and you come in you
give me a pound with your wart hand why
just listen to the wart hand and um you
very been distant lately it toward me
you don't call me you don't really talk
to me one time I texted to you you did
not respond but that's just a given I
was on your birthday oh I put I put I
wrote your name on my butt cheek and I
said that and you sent me a thing yeah
remember I send out a thing of like
congratulating you or something your
birthday or like the show and I showed
out of careful yeah but have I'm not
going to but have I hurt you no you I've
never hurt you let me hurt me like
physically no I've ever like you know
just made you mad where you went off
[ __ ] that guy when we first met but I
know we gotta fight one so then I
realized that was like yeah yeah we
threatened to leave or something yeah
but no yeah no not I've never felt hurt
by you
I really haven't do you love me I talked
to my mom about this do you love me not
tell you I talked to my mom oh my I do
do you love me more though I want you to
be completely honest I this is a time
and place for it because
not ask you here apron is no no I I love
both of you know do you love me more
though I probably work closer as I
probably love ya thank you yeah and no
late and that's the truth and that's
fine
and I can take it and I love it cuz it's
honesty yeah but can I just say this
right that's here now but do you love
her more than me no I love you the same
I love you the same all right
I feel better I'm kidding babe come on
oh hey hey babe hey George you kalila
thank you Wow he's gonna remember that
do now so for all you [ __ ] that
think I'm a [ __ ] yeah
[Music]